[Music]
the historian Mahon the hit Broadway
musical Hamilton is award-winning author
Ron chernow his biography of bounding
father Alexander Hamilton has sold more
than a million copies across all formats
Letourneau is back with his seventh book
it is called grant it chronicles the
life of Civil War general and 18th u.s.
president ulysses s grant Ron chernow
joins us now we're pleased to have him
back at the table welcome I am pleased
to be here Charlie thank you so for most
biographer like you the first question
might be why grant well you know I
always had this fantasy of writing a big
sweeping saga about the Civil War and
reconstruction and grant is the person
who is at the center of that it's really
two acts of the the same drama and just
if you look through the prism of ulysses
s grant life everything's significant
that happens between 1861 and 1877 he is
right smack at the center of it what
what made him the great general he was
well I think you know and he doesn't get
credit for that as you point out you
know it's very interesting because
Robert Ely is I was glorified as the
great general but grant captured three
Confederate armies at Fort Donaldson in
1862 and Vicksburg in 1863 most famously
Appomattox in 1865 and yet Lee is the
one who's romanticized as the great in
general robbery Lee never captured a
Union Army grant was a decisive he was
determined he was aggressive and
unlikely who had plans for winning
individual battles ulysses s grant had a
strategy from winning the entire war and
he did that charlie by he took all the
Union armies which had been operating
independently and he coordinated that so
that they were functioning as a single
fighting unit and that was the winning
strategy while he seemed to drink quite
a bit as you point out in the book he
was described as a drunkard and had to
promise people I promise not to drink
before we go to battle well what I've
tried to do Gail you know in this book
is to change the terms of the
controversy was granted drunkard who was
grant an alcoholic and he was an hour I
feel with you no drunkard that there's
it's a Victorian
term it implies the drinking is immoral
failing nowadays we know that alcohol
as a chronic disease and Grant had it
once he took one drink he could not stop
drinking it triggered off an extreme
personality change he became a rather
jovial and silly personality and what I
discovered was that there was a definite
pattern to his drinking because a lot of
people in good faith said I never saw a
grain drink but what he would do he
would not touch a drop of alcohol for
two or three-month periods after a major
battle he would then go up to a small
town on a side trip have a two or three
day bender that his officers and his men
never saw and then he would come back as
William Tecumseh Sherman said fresh as a
rose when I would tell this story to my
friends in AAA they were all said the
same thing
ulysses s grant was a high-functioning
alcoholic as you mentioned it ran and
his family as well he served in the
Mexican War and you talked about in the
book how as far as grant was concerned
the Civil War was in large part a
consequence of the Mexican War can you
explain that a bit more right because
you know the abolitionists felt that by
adding Texas and other territories in
the south and southwest of the Union
that these would potentially become
slave states and wouldn't expand the
power of the slave Empire grant was
although he fought with distinction in
the Mexican War he said that it was the
most unjust war in his view ever waged
by a stronger nation against a weaker
nation and indeed the acquisition of
territory after the victorious war
against Mexico did ignite the debate
about abolition I'm interested in how I
thought about lead did what was his
media prospectively became a story that
yeah that when he accepted the surrender
as Lee was coming back you know the
Union soldiers made a certain grant
respected Lee but he also thought that
Lee was highly overrated and he said
Robert Lee was a man who needed sunshine
he felt that Lee was actually
politically operating in a much more
much easier environment in the in the
south where he was constantly glorified
by a grant in the north where there was
a lot of anti-war sentiment the
so-called Copperhead the Democrats grant
fed felt that he was constantly being
denigrated from his own side so that Lee
had a lot of advantages grant had
more advantages in terms of man pyar but
Li was fighting on home territory Li was
fighting a defensive war which is much
easier Li had all of these spies who
could track the the Union movements and
grant had to protect his very long
supply lines going down from the north
and to the south people talk about great
memoirs they talk about Charles de
Gaulle you know and they talk about
ulysses s grant and then they suggest
that his friend or was he is friend Mark
Twain may have had some impact on role
and it was a memoir he didn't want to
write I thought that was he didn't want
to write it year before he died he was
financially wiped out by the Bernie
Madoff of his day at the same time he
was diagnosed with cancer of the throat
and tongue and excruciating way to die
and in excruciating pain
he wrote this memoir during the last
year of his life Charlie so many people
ask me did Twain write the memorize that
I went down to the Library of Congress
and I said show me the original
manuscript I went through every page of
the original manuscript just to verify
that the manuscript you Mrs S grads
handwriting and the Twain said of grants
memoirs the stylus flawless no man can
improve upon that and I don't think that
how come you didn't write here there was
a Twain connection though to the man
well he was such a good writer because
granted always prided himself on his
writing he wrote all his own word
tidewaters Charlie he wrote all of his
own speeches as president so in a way
and he was also considered a great
raconteur and people had heard him tell
these stories in seven-way it's not so
surprising he produced what is now
thought to be the greatest you know
military memoir in American letters the
twine connection though is because yeah
the Twain connect Wayne published the
book published that's my publisher
Charlie saying yeah absolutely
oasis of musical or not yes no I think
yes Lynn when he was here what Lynn say
well I think it's safe to say that
grants lab does not move to a hip-hop
beat big book Ron chernow grant goes on
sale tomorrow wherever you like to buy
your books and you can hear more of the
CBS this morning on our podcast on
iTunes and Apple podcast out